hi there steve kaufman another glorious
day here in vancouver
and uh again i'm going to talk about
language learning of course but i'm
going to talk about language learning
and money
and it's a subject that sometimes people
don't like to associate with learning or
with education the idea of money
money
kind of makes learning dirty education
should be free
language learning should be free
everything on the internet should be
free
so there's this tremendous sort of
anti-commercial bias
in our society and it's not just in our
society it's not just a matter of
teachers or universities today and
culticating the idea that everything
should be free free is morally good
anything that has a dollar sign attached
to it is bad that's been around since
the beginning of time
i think in ancient china and in europe
you know the priests and the soldiers
and the rulers and the aristocracy were
considered much higher on the totem pole
than the money-grubbing merchants
but in reality whenever
culture has flourished the arts have
flourished music
good food
new technology all of the kinds of
things advances in medicine these have
always taken place
during periods when
commerce flourished and it was the
merchants who made things happen the
merchants who were i mean tang china
which was this great flowering of of
culture and printing and the arts
uh was also a period of great commercial
activity the silk road
rice moving from southern china to the
north
uh hangzhou great commercial center
you know active traders from
uh from central asia and um
commercial contacts with korea and
and and japan and so forth and it was
the same in uh
you know florence uh or at least in if
you look in in so far as the uh
you know the late middle ages and the
development of the renaissance it was
commercial centers like flanders
and tuscany and and the other cities in
italy that
that spurred this great you know
cultural and
literary and philosophical and musical
flowering
so uh i always
kind of have difficulty with the fact
that the the soldiers and the priests
you know genghis khan is glorious
because he killed lots of people but the
merchants are just money grubbers so
that's just to get things started and
many of the things that we enjoy in life
again food the farmer likes to get paid
um
you know historically artists have been
supported by people with money
people have no money can't support an
artist
so get us back to education
a good teacher
or a person who writes
a very good textbook
um
people who create
rosetta stone whatever
all those people need to be compensated
for
their efforts
um
you know when i went to study romanian i
found people through elance who would
translate
uh english sentences phrases patterns
that i wanted into romanian and record
them for me i paid them they wouldn't do
it for free
now i'm not against obviously
volunteerism
uh we had big floods in the city of
calgary in canada
and lots of people helped their
neighbors there was a great
sort of attitude of mutual help
but those people who were helping their
neighbors
they all have jobs
because they all nevertheless need to
earn in order to buy the things that
they need so let's bring this back to
language learning every time i learn a
language i spend money
i buy books or i buy the services of a
tutor i buy the services of someone who
can help me by translating or
transcribing
uh
and yet i also take advantage of
whatever is free
i listen to podcasts i download
podcasts and transcripts so
i'm not obliged to spend money
but because i enjoy language learning
i do spend money and money is an
extremely useful invention because
without money
if i didn't have the means of sending
via paypal
money to romania to have
uh this material transcribed for me or
recorded for me
i couldn't have it done i couldn't say
uh
i will take out your garbage in romania
for a week or i will cut your lawn or i
will do some service for you i'll give
you a massage
once a day for seven days there's no
service that i can provide
uh it's far more convenient for me to
simply say how much do you want
so that that person gets some money that
they then can spend in however they want
to spend it so money liberates you
to
earn for your
efforts and skills and labor
a medium exchange that you can take
somewhere else and buy things that
matter to you
now
learning should be free education should
be free language learning should be free
why
it's something that i value
i value
learning languages more than buying a
starbucks coffee
so i'm happy to spend money on a book
in czech so i can read about the history
of czechoslovakia other people don't
want to do that they'll spend their
money on
coffee cigarettes
hiking boots skiing trips whatever it
might be
but since learning is of value and of
course we spend a fortune on education
we spend a fortune
between government spending and private
spending
in
most countries at seven eight nine ten
percent of gdp it's a fortune and the
only decision that has to be made is
whether how much of that spending should
be done by the individual
the
in the individual consumer of those
educational services and how much
should be paid for by the community at
large in the form of taxes or other
means of supporting these institutions
including donations
but all of these are rational decisions
that people have to make and you don't
have to spend money to learn languages
you can go to the library and you can
borrow
whatever you need and you can meet with
people you don't have to meet for a
coffee you can meet in the park if you
can somehow contact
people
who have who speak the language that you
so you have these meetups that are
organized through the internet but even
the internet even google all of those
things there is a mel an element where
those
um people behind google have to make
money to pay their employees so you
can't escape from the commercial
aspects of all of these activities and
there is nothing wrong with people
providing a service
for
a return and it's up to the consumer to
decide
whether link is worth it for example or
not worth it rosetta stone is worth it
or not worth it uh
signing up for a course at a local
community college is worth it or not
worth it those are decisions that each
person makes as a consumer just as they
decide whether they want to buy a big
car or a small car now there is a
problem with money
because money is identified with power
and so the problem in a sense is
inequality so we have inequality of
money we have inequality of possessions
we have inequality of power in a society
and that's true of any society including
communist so-called egalitarian
societies inequality is always there of
course
the less unequal society is the more
comfortable a place usually it is to
live in all other things being equal
however is if
inequality or excuse me if equality is
imposed
by means of drastic restrictions of
freedom
drastic restrictions of the freedom to
produce products to own your own home to
own your own farm for farming purposes
in other words if we look at some of
these idealistic experiments
which led to totalitarian governments
where
individual freedom was restricted
the results were not so happy so there
is no perfect world there is no
perfectly equal society there is no
society where everybody just
gives to everyone else because the
nature of human beings is that we do
have this tendency to look after our own
interests
and
the use of money as a medium of exchange
whereby
someone who's interested in my services
will pay me for my for what i provide
and i will take the money and then use
it to buy things that are of interest to
me that seems to work well so i guess
what i'm saying is i don't understand
this tremendous aversion to quote
commercialism in education
education is extremely important in our
society the greater variety of
educational services that are available
for people to choose from the better
some will be financed by government
some will not be financed by government
not every
educational service offered by the
government is necessarily effective good
value or useful so
by all means government
should
provide educational services as a means
of mitigating against inequality in a
society and i 100 support the idea of
publicly funded schooling right up to
grade 12.
would even support publicly funded
schooling right up through university if
there were
total freedom of choice but the way
things work right now
universities have become sort of
bastions of privilege for the people who
work in the system
and for those who are lucky enough to
get in
so i don't think that's such a great
model i would rather see a model where
the state financed
uh the sort of distribution of
educational services free to everyone
via the internet uh or whatever other
means without having this tremendous
cost of supporting
uh
this this very heavy uh infrastructure
of teachers and administrators and so
forth there are that are associated with
public education today public funding
yes a more decentralized and efficient
way of delivering educational services
would be better so i've kind of rambled
a bit i wanted to get this off my chest
i look forward to your feedback thank
you for listening bye for now